Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Welcome to another episode of our Cutters Clinic podcast.
Today we have a special guest, Pastor Jason Garwood, who wrote a book that I endorsed.
You published that one a year ago, wasn't it?
Yes, it came out in the about fall of 2020, yes, about a little over a year ago.
All right, a great book titled Health for All of Life, really a book of, I think it was, it's in
and filling a niche really, because Christians, the Whartigan Christians in America have to be kind
told the line of standard medicine. And I remember in a church, a Baptist church,
a very years ago, I had to defend myself all the time for being a chiropractor, because
why did you become a real doctor? And you know, it's basically like I was practicing
voodoo, practicing chiropractic. I mean how unbelievably
backwards that is, but really practicing pharma tia is practicing voodoo.
So I want to start asking you, but how did you get into, you know, being a pastor of a church,
how did you get into health, wellness, thought process? Yeah, yeah, that's a good question,
because it's sort of a unique thing. I don't know of another book that exists like it,
you know, just bridging the gap between theology, doctrine, the world view that we have in
scripture and the Christian worldview, and then speaking into something like health, certainly,
you know, politics and religion are off topic, you know, at the family dinner, but we sort of
blend everything together in that. And I guess how I really got started was because of my wife.
She, for most of our marriage was just very ill, would experience disease and symptoms,
and just sort of in the evening time she would crash, she was very tired, and a lot of it was
diet, of course she needed to change what she was eating, and we all did. But for her, she struggled
with lime, and essentially figuring out what it was about lime, and what basically she treated
herself like she had cancer. What would I do if I had cancer? How do I get my body? How do I detox
my body? How do I get the parasites out of there? And how do I heal my cells? And that was kind
of the journey we went on maybe eight or nine years ago. And that's kind of how it all started,
really, for us, was just experience. We were thrown into it, thrust into it. She found some
tremendous resources from Chris Wark. He wrote a book called Chris Beat Cancer, and there are other
solid books that are out there that talk about the underlying cause of disease being a lack of nutrition
or some sort of imbalance, a lack of homeostasis in the body. And so kind of what happened,
though, was once we got her figured out that it was sort of on to me, what do I need to do to be
healthier? And taking care of our family, and how do we want to educate our kids too so they can
have self-government over this area of their life? And that's, I guess that's kind of where it all came
from. And then I was thrust into the conversation through vaccines. I did a sermon on vaccination
and really just teased out the underlying issues in the world view that's at play here when we
how we view the human body. And so that got a lot of traction on Facebook, Facebook, of course,
killed that video after about almost 70,000 views. And it's gone. It's nowhere to be found. And
it's secretly still on YouTube for now. But yeah, I participated in a lot of health freedom rallies
even before COVID hit. But that's sort of the nutshell, really, how I got started is just experience
and working through it. And then me deciding, I need to take control of my health too. I can't just
leave it to the MDs who are just going to prescribe some sort of synthetic drug that's going to
mask symptoms, but not really deal with the underlying issue. Well, we see that so often is that
somebody through experiential dealings with standards of care didn't have a solution for when you
talk about Lyme disease eight years ago, the standard of care for Lyme disease is that chronic
Lyme didn't exist. Now they're starting to recognize it, but they have no treatment for it. So
you had to seek out something other than the medical doctor down the street. And I like that
point that you made about self-goverty. You're you're taking back the control of your health.
You're putting that responsibility back on you as an individual, you as a father or your family.
Talk a little bit about that. Yeah, yeah, I think that that's really the foundation of it all.
As a pastor and a theologian, a writer, or somebody who's engaged in and the scriptures constantly
and trying to navigate that for myself and of course for our church. And what we want to do with
the great commission, all of those things sort of intersect together. And when you look at for
example, Colation's five, one of the fruit of the spirit is self-control. So basically when it comes
down to it, all of us have some sort of accountability to God as being made in his image. And as people who
are made it made in his image, we are required to act a certain way. We are required to
you know, be be self-governed people. And when when we come to faith in Christ and the gospel
renews us and changes us and the Holy Spirit works in us. And that's one of the foundational things
that we get as we get this gift of self-government. So we get to grow in our sanctification and
taking control of ourselves and our actions and how we speak of others. So everything from
putting to death deeds of the body like sexual immorality or a whole host of things, we also get
to put to death those things that you know, may not be like the big, heavy sins, but it could be
something as simple as gossiping about somebody. We have a responsibility before God to be accountable
for our actions and even our thoughts too. The Bible tells us that even our thoughts will be judged
by God. And so that's why I think I emphasize especially with health for all of life is this need
to take control of it. We typically farm out our responsibilities. The children are carted off to the
government schools and you find that parents are just trying to make more and more money to get that
huge house and the huge boat. And we sort of grind it out for a lot of things that we almost miss
what's in front of us. And we kind of fail to forget or excuse me, we fail to see what it is
that is right in front of us and the blessings that God gives us. So we want to have perspective
essentially. We want to give people control over their health. Don't farm it out to people. Don't
pastors and elders shouldn't be the only ones doing the Bible reading, for example.
You shouldn't just farm out your responsibility for what you put in your body, whether it's food or
medicine or what have you, which usually those are the same thing. You need to not just trust
in whatever TV commercial is going to come out and tell you, hey, if you have these symptoms,
you should try this drug. And the side effects might include your ears fall off and you can't see
anymore. But you know, maybe that issue will be resolved. So we have to take control of ourselves.
I see that as a major point, it just in practice, the 37 years I've been in practice is that
I think it's part of our total depravity that we don't want to take responsibility for things.
Yeah. Because then that is that puts a burden on us that we have to answer to God for some
set of knowledge that we are to gain in order to take responsibility for that thing. Whether it is
our health or I don't want to read the Bible. I'll let my pastor do that. Your spiritual walk
and we could go on and on and on. I think that's a piece of original sin is that we want to push
that responsibility on to others so that I don't have to deal with it. Somehow it's going to
magically go away and resolve itself. And you see that? I think I just totally agree with the
things that you wrote in this book is that is a major problem in the church. And we live in an era
of relative prosperity compared to other eras and a sense of that we can do that when you talk
about health care. Well, I'm just going to let the medical doctor deal with that and I'll let him
tell me what to take or tell me what to do. I'm not going to do any of my old research. And especially
these last two years people have been shunned and made fun of doing their own research. And I think
that so Christian should stand up the church and stand up and say that's that is
wrong theology right there. Yeah. Yeah. I don't think I considered it. Say that any better especially
with pursuing knowledge and the pursuit that we have with you heard Dr. Fauci. I guess I should
put that in quotes because it's remains to be seen at this point. But you know a question me,
you question science. Well, science invites questioning. That's the whole point of it. We're
supposed to do that. And is it the basis of science? Yes, it's investigation. Exactly. Yeah.
Very sad. Very sad. Yeah. We are going to pay for our ignorance. And whether it's here or we're
going to have to answer God for it. Or you see people paid for their ignorance now making very
foolish health care decisions and suffering greatly. And it's one thing. If an adult does that,
it's another thing. What an adult brings their child and you talk about getting vaccinated or
something like that. And going to get foolishly getting this shot. I don't know what I'll call it a
vaccine experiment. Yes, it's just horrible. Yeah. Yeah. Well, what else? What was your other underlying
purpose of this? But what did you want to get out to the church? So I think if you were to,
yeah, it's just sort of like a 30 second. And then I'll expand upon it. At the basic level,
we want, as we've already said, we want to promote self-government. We want people to do their
research to see that what they're being told on the television or from NIH or you know all these
other government protected organizations like the CDC. It's not the whole story. In fact,
a lot of that's just obfuscated for financial gain. We already know about the FDA's revolving door
with big pharma executives and how there's just this constant scratching each other's back to do
each other favors. And it's all, it's all status control. So we all know that's out there. But we
want to try to disrupt that. And we want to say no, that's not the whole truth. In fact, there's a
whole lot more that you're not being told. And so health, fall of life is essentially the subtitle
is a medical manifesto. And it's a medical manifesto of hope and healing for the nations. So for me,
as a pastor, I want to see the nations disciple. I want to see them come to Christ. I want to see them
saved. I want to see them have hope and joy and peace walking in the light of the Lord. But part of
that though is getting rid of some faulty theology as well. So the book starts with an understanding of
theology, a holistic, a comprehensive view of the gospel. And that comprehensive view comes to us
from the New Testament itself as we understand what Jesus came to do. He said that he came to
inaugurate the kingdom of God on earth as it is in heaven. The very first words of the gospel of
mark were repent and believe the gospel that this kingdom of God is near, repent and believe the gospel.
So we have to stop with, and this is part of, again, the mission of the first couple of chapters of
the book. But we have to stop viewing all of these areas of life, whether it's politics or health,
medicine, education, economics, all of these things, we have to stop viewing them as if they're
just secondary issues or tertiary issues. And the real thing is just for us to walk around like
functional Buddhists being spiritually enlightened. And Frances Schaeffer talks about this two stories
to a house. The upper story is that story of grace, the immaterial, the spiritual, and then we're all
stuck down here in this first floor with the material and what we see in front of us in the world. And
and a lot of people just assume, well, to get to the upstairs, you just sort of have to mentally put
yourself there and or read your Bible and pray. And then you can sort of, you know, existentially put
yourself there. And the Christian worldview says, no, no, no, we are complete. We're a whole
beast. This is kind of the language I use in the book. We are a body soul and spirit. Now we're not
simply just a body that is holding the real valuables, the soul. No, God made us whole. He made us
complete. So there really is no upper and lower story in the Christian worldview. There's just the
world. And we're in it. And we're made in God's image. And we do have souls and we have a spirit.
And we also have a body. So I think a lot of Christians sort of function like a platonic dualists.
Dualism is a huge problem in our theology where as long as you're going to church reading your
Bible and praying, everything's fine, but don't spend too much time at all researching health or how
you can prevent cancer or how you can heal Lyme or I know stuff, things that you have written about,
excellent resources. And I want to blow that whole thinking up. And that really was was my hope
with the book is to say, no, we have a comprehensive kingdom that we serve the Lord Jesus Christ within.
And all things matter, all things matter. If we're going to teach the nations how to obey Christ,
which is what Matthew 28 says, then we need to help them and equip them with a very basic view
of of health. How do you how do you get someone to understand the importance of
neutrifying the body or detoxing the body or energizing the body? That's the the three-legged stool
that I talk about in the book. And you know, so that's sort of a little bit of a longer explanation,
but I think that that that's the key aspect and what drove me to want to write the book is getting
the theology right, helping people to sort through why we have this big, wonderful world and God
has given it to us. And a lot of things usually when I talk about this, I like to talk about creation
based medicine. And creation based medicine, you think about the incredible herbs that God has given
us and their healing power. The purified water does just an unbelievable amount of good for the body.
You know, all these things that God has given us in creation, we just need to figure out how to harness
them, how to balance the body, how to keep things into, you know, homeostasis. But don't reject it.
You know, don't just stuff your body with Oreos and donuts and say, well, I'm going to have them when I die.
Yeah. There's more to it than that. That's right. I agree. Yeah. See, this is my listeners are listening
to you and going, oh, no, I don't want Dr. Cutter is interviewing this guy thinks the exact same way.
Sometimes it's good to have a guest sound that have a different point of view and sometimes it's
good to have guests sound that are supporting our point of view. And I thank you for doing that.
Yeah.
Well, this book will have information on your book all over this podcast and so that our listeners
could get to it. Highly recommend it for believers, especially to really put those things together.
I totally agree that we've been kind of living in in Christiandom in this dualistic nature that,
well, if we have a real problem, then we got to run to the real doctor kind of thing. But our spiritual
life is separate than that. And what you're doing is saying you can't separate the systems.
Our spirit, our soul, our body, our one. And we need to take responsibility for all three of those
things. Well, you know, while we're here on earth. And yes, we trusted a sovereign God, but it is
our responsibility to do something about and to know how to take care of ourselves. Right.
Yeah. And then there are blueprints. And that's the thing, too, to emphasize is like we're not coming
at it. This from an evolutionary perspective where we're just all, you know, walking meat bags who
crawled out of the pond after millions and billions of years. We're coming at it from, no, the body
is a uniquely designed thing. And God is our creator. And he's given it to us to figure out and
steward and investigate. And that's beautiful. It's a good thing. Yeah. It's a good thing.
And there's knowledge to be gained. So we are here to study and to learn to show ourselves
approved not just to be able to witness the words of the gospel, but to be able to have our
lives be a witness for the gospel. So be that living gospel that people could look at and see
you know, where did we put our faith in. I found it amazing just the last two years.
Amazing and very sorrowful to see professing Christians just just be so fearful over a virus.
Over even if it was going to be as deadly as was originally proclaimed. I think back in history
during the black plague, it was Christians that were going to house to house,
ministry to people that had just a few days to live with a disease that was so contagious
that if you got it, you were pretty much guaranteed to die. But they just looked at their purpose
administering to people as bigger than their purpose of surviving this earth and living for another
X about a years. And I just see the faithlessness in people who are professing Christians. It's sad.
And that's really kind of what you're bringing out in this book. That's why I enjoyed it so much,
is that you can't separate your Sunday faith from your Monday life. Yeah. They're not two different
things. And we want to do that. I think that's part of our sinful nature again,
not take your responsibility for what God has called us to be responsible for.
Yeah, you're bringing up the past couple of years. I mean, we've all lived through quite a tumultuous
time unprecedented on every level with regard to the state's response and control over things. I don't
know if you saw, but this is starting to make national news. But our local hospital that's about
10 minutes from where I'm sitting right now in my office is going through this huge issue because
the family wanted Ivermect in the hospital wouldn't prescribe it. The court, a judge,
ordered it to be prescribed and they're not doing it. So it's huge. It's, I mean, it's just insane.
So when you think about unprecedented things, I mean, that's sort of a medical technocracy is
officially taken over. And you know, it's your point about the history and how Christians have responded.
You know, I would love to have been able to, well, I'll say this before I, let me
preface it by saying this, Christians by and large. And there are many waking up. A lot of people
are. And I praise God for that. Certainly people I've interacted with on gab and in other places have
have sort of, they see that the charade is sort of, okay, now it's, it's kind of a problem now.
But many Christians, instead of helping and figuring out ways to assist by taking the principles
like in this book, for example, and implementing them, many Christians decided, no, we're just going
to go along with it. We're going to wear the mask and we're going to do what we're told. We're going to,
we're going to, you know, starve our bodies of oxygen by wearing these things all day. And who
had done that before? We haven't seen that. Not in my generation or yours. And so all this unprecedented
stuff and Christians just sort of rolled over. And I would love to have set up a stand and said,
hey, come, you know, come get educated on what you can do with zinc and vitamins A, B, C, the whole
gamut, chlorine dioxide. Come learn about that and how that can help your body prophylactically deal with
certain sickness and disease. But if I would have done that, I would have been arrested. Helping people
on the street corner with COVID. So we just sort of ran in the opposite direction. It's really,
it's really sad and unfortunate. In fact, Florence Nightingale, one thing that impressed her about
Christ was what was kind of a famous quote of hers. But she Christ always went to the sick. He always
went to them. He didn't sequester himself from them. He went to them and what a remarkable picture of
what Christians could do if they had the principles that are put forth in this book and books like
yours, put those principles into place and start really getting out of the, you know, with a grip of
the alipathic, modern medicine, Kabbal is what I like to call them. It is a Kabbal. And we're living
in the middle of a cult like thinking where people that are professing believers are just dived,
rated, you know, dead and shoulders with it. Yeah, that's, that's very sad.
If you're putting an angel on the top of your tree that has a mask over it, you're in the cult.
You're in the cult. You're in the cult.
Would wholeheartedly agree.
Well, one of the main points that you want somebody to take home when you read a book, you don't
always remember everything that you read. What are your main points that you want to
hold it in? Yeah. Yeah. Well, that's good because this is kind of the exciting part for me is
because, you know, I had probably read three or four thousand pages of material to research for this
book. I just was jumped right into my friend Bill Evans helped finance the project and he is the one
who helped get the website started healthforalloflife.com and so there's a lot out there and so you can
sift through it. But I sifted through it because I wanted to try to give people a bird's eye view
something practical they can do action steps they can take. Really just try to bring all of this
wealth of information from tons of incredible doctors, Dr. Joel Wallach and Dr. Jerry Tenet and others
who have been doing this for a very, very, very, very long time. Let's pull all that together and let's
make sure that we have a Christian worldview and voila. There's the book and I really kind of after
the theology part of the book, I wanted to talk about health and sickness and what it actually is and
isn't because there's a lot of misnomers there as well. I traced a little bit of the history of the
Flexner Report of 1910 which really changed modern medicine here in the West and how that really became
now a status controlled nightmare as we've seen for the past two years. But really the rest of the book
is just here are the seven cell building essentials and they're geared around the triad of truth,
the three things. Nutrify detoxify and energize and I'm just going to walk through those a little bit
briefly. If that's okay with you, just to give people an idea of what we're talking about and
all of these things have really like a spiritual lesson that ties with it. For example, the first of
the three is Nutrify. So you have Nutrify detoxify and energize and if you can kind of remember those
three aspects, you can kind of, you know, work yourself from there. And Nutrify really kind of
enjoins itself to this idea that we're supposed to feed on Christ. He's our bread of life. So as such,
we need the first cell building essential is healthy nutrition. So you unfortunately you I'm sure along
with our viewers are up to speed on the devastation of the tornadoes that happened in Kentucky and
even Arkansas the past few days and so our prayers are with them. A lot of people died and a lot of
people lost things. So I don't want this analogy to be misappropriated here, but if a tornado were to
hit a home, how would you repair it? And that's how we view health. What do you need to do? And
that first cell building essential is health and nutrition. You need new materials to rebuild the home.
So there are certain things you need to avoid, right? Hydrogenated or partially,
hydrogenated oils, refined sugars, excitotoxins like aspirate, MSG, those types of things are all
dangerous. So there are things you just need to avoid. There are things you just need to stop eating,
stop consuming so much high fructose corn syrup, you know, which seems to be in everything,
like catch up especially. But there are things you do need to, I recommend listeners pick up the
China study by Dr. Colin T. Colin Campbell, a wonderful study, tremendous amounts of research on
nutrition and what nutrition looks looks like. For example, berries. I mean, berries, there's so many
studies that have been done on just on berries, strawberries, blueberries, especially their anti-cancer
incredible resources that God's given us as food and creation. So we need to be eating the healthy
stuff. But I kind of, they're really the core part of healthy nutrition. That first cell building
essential is the mighty 90, the 90 for life. That's Dr. Joel Wallach's research. 60 essential minerals.
You got calcium, iodine, iron magnesium, even oxygens and their selenium zinc. But you also have
16 essential vitamins. So vitamin A, you got B1, 2, 3, 5, CDEK, all of those. You have 12 essential
amino acids as well. And then of course, the three essential fatty acids and cholesterol. So
those are the 90 essential nutrients. And a lot of Dr. Wallach's research has been interesting because
he says essentially all diseases can be traced back to a lack of proper nutrition. And that's different
because if you go to the regular doctor today, they're not going to ask you what are you eating?
How are you sleeping? How much sunlight are you getting? Are you stressed out in your life? You know,
they're not asking any of those questions. I have headaches. Well, here, just take this.
Right. No, no questions about nutrition at all.
Yeah. And they get caused for the deficiency of the intractor or something.
Right. Right. So you need those, you need those vitamins and minerals. You need those things.
Calcium is the most abundant mineral in the human body. Obviously found in bone and teeth,
but it helps. It works well with magnesium and zinc and all of these things with it contributes
to serotonin levels in your brain and those types of things. I think it was Dr. Glittin who said that
a lack of calcium actually contributes to about 147 diseases. So that's fascinating.
Magnesium, of course, is there helps transferring energy, making use of proteins and so on at
the cellular level. So for us, when we talk about the cell building essentials like healthy nutrition,
that's a big one. I mean, that's really, I think you would agree with that. That's a huge aspect
to health is making sure your body has to have the materials. If you're going to rebuild the home,
it has to have good materials, things like humic and folic acid, electrolytes, they help maintain
healthy cellular membrane. So you sort of zoom in to the cellular level and say, what are these
trillions of cells in my body need? What do I need to provide for them? Right. And you are always
rebuilding the home because it's always breaking down. These cells are diagnosed through apoptosis.
You're always creating new cells. You need this at a daily basis. Yeah. Yeah. So and again,
that goes against the whole alipathic model of convention. What we have now today, rather than
naturopathic or homeopathic model of medicine, this alipathic model is built on evolution.
It's built on pagan presuppositions. These are all just, you know, little parts that can be taken
in and out of the body. So that's why, you know, synthetic drugs, when they're prescribed, they really
only mask your symptoms. They don't deal with the issues that are underlining. So
even the endocannabinoid system plays into that too with regard to
helping the body, the chemical makeup in your body. So that's the first thing,
cell building essential. Number one, I'm going to try to go a little bit. It goes through them.
People can pick up the book if they want. But the second one, under the neutral fire heading,
is having a healthy hydration. So clean water. If you're going to rebuild a home, you've got to have
clean water. The human bodies upwards of 65% water. We use at our house a burky filter.
And we're on well water as it is. But drinking clean water is super, super important.
Getting rid of heavy metals and fluoride and other toxins. Those are all aspects of having
healthy water. And I would point listeners to CLO2.tv for a really wonderful documentary on chlorine
dioxide. And it's really one of the best safest and most inexpensive detoxifying agents known to man.
It's not. It's not bleach. But you got Dr. Manuel
apparicio. I can't always remember how to pronounce his last name. But he's been treating COVID
patients with it in Mexico. But CD, chlorine dioxide is a selective killer. It destroys pathogens,
viruses, which in my view are more of exosome secretions. But fungi, bacteria, rogue cells,
it kind of loosens that envelope, the viral envelope. And then it deactivates,
destroys the cells. So it's an oxidizer. It's something that it pushes oxygen to the cells.
It enhances your metabolic functions. And it's just a wonderful,
wonderful tool. And basically two parts. You get one jar and another. And you combine those and
chlorine dioxide, sodium chloride. And you activate it with hydrochloric acid.
So yeah, as far as water goes though, water is incredibly important. So that's
neutrified. That's the first triad of truth. The second one is detoxify.
You detoxifies another leg of this health stool. And biblically, it kind of goes along with this idea
of repenting of sin. Exactly. What doctor's going to tell you? What sins have you been committing?
Because that could be aiding and abetting in your health problems and your
sonic issues. But healthy detoxification, that's the third cell building essential. You got to
you got to clear the debris if you're going to rebuild the home. And so things like intermittent fasting
are great or extended fasting burns fat. It helps with energy, reduces inflammation, inflammation
as you know, I mean, that's really in a lot of ways. That's the name of the game is getting
your inflammation under control. Fasting helps spiritually. It helps too to just focus your thoughts.
You may be in a season of stress and you need to just stop and process and think and perhaps meditate
and see how God would want you to respond. But detoxing looks like a whole lot of things.
Liver detoxing, you know, removing those toxins, coffee enemas are just something we use in our house.
It's one of those things that nobody really likes to talk a whole lot about. But man, are they
incredible for clearing out the liver? Oh, we talk about those all the times. Good, good, good, good.
I suppose that people are watching there familiar with it. But gallbladder cleanse is same thing. Stop,
don't eat so much food. The gallbladder, a lot of people aren't even familiar with what it does,
but essentially it's a storage house. It stores bile. It helps aid in the digestive process. So
don't eat so much, so many of the foods that are inflammation driven, too much dairy, sugars,
certain oils can all contribute to that. kidney cleanses. All those things are all important aspects
of detoxing, detoxing body. One of my favorite things I have actually with me right here is called
Advanced TRS. It's made by Kosova. And it's a zeolite that some people may or may not be familiar
with here if you're listening, but it's a zeolite. It's simply a cage shaped structure. It's put in
water and it goes wherever water goes in your body, which is everywhere. And it basically binds to
heavy metals. And when it binds those things, it helps you detox it safely from the body. And this is
something if you've had vaccines in the past, I personally recommend that you have this. I take it
basically almost every day, just a few squirts of it and try to keep my body clear. So that's detoxing.
The fourth cell building essential is healthy immune and lymphatic systems. So you need a sewer
system. You've got to have your immune system in play. I know this is a topic you are quite familiar
with, too. And it's certainly one that we need to discuss given the nature of the experimental jab
that's being forced on our population. But the immune system, you have a cell mediated in a
humoral system. You have the cell mediated is really like the air lane and sea attack. It destroys
the pathogenic material, whether that's viruses and toxins, neurotoxins, bacteria, fungus, other
things like that. It eats them. The system disarms them. It pushes them out. That's why you get mucus
or a rash on your body or a fever. It's breathing itself. But then the humoral is sort of like the
communication system. It comes along after the fights over. It hands a piece of that antigen from
whatever toxin that was. It records it and it basically puts it on a hit list. And that's what,
that's how the body knows. But with the immune system, this is the thing about vaccination. I do
not mind being called an anti-vaxer. I'm okay with it. And that's because I think that it does
more damage than good. And I understand why they do it. But the vaccine suppresses that first line
cell mediated system. And then it tries to activate the humoral system so that basically you can get more
antibodies produced. But the problem is you're basically running a trick play on your body. The body
that God gave you with a system that He gave you in place. So it's essentially the two main issues
with vaccination. It's a dysregulation of the immune system and it causes havoc. But then you
all this will have this molecular mimicry where cells will pick up that antigen, that small genetic
sequence. And it won't be able to determine what that is with regard to the rest of the body. So that's
why I believe vaccines cause autism because it starts attacking the body. And especially when it crosses
the blood brain barrier, you have neurological problems after vaccination, especially the MMR is the
most notable one out of anyone. Now, the new mRNA vaccine, they're basically trying to trick your DNA
and your genetic sequencing therein to produce the antibodies. So it's even different type of
vaccine. That's why we can't even really call the vaccine. I would say that the practice of
standard medicine, one could argue there's ability for it, there's a place for it. When you get into
vaccines, you're talking about a completely different world view though. Yeah. And you are basically
going around everything that God, how God created your body to work. Thinking that you have more
knowledge than that, and that you could do a better job than how God, how you were created to respond
to pathogens in your environment. But there's real danger. But you start, you've crossed the line,
you're not walking on the fed city board, you've crossed the line into a completely different world view.
Yeah. Yeah. No, I agree. And that's why I'm comfortable being called an anti-vaxer because
for me, I reject Darwinian evolution as an explanation for our origins. So I biologically rejected,
but even just practically as it roots, it sort of rears its ugly head today in medicine and just
how would they treat the human body and view the human body? I just reject it. I don't think it's
I don't think it's good. I don't think it works. And it causes more harm than good.
It's a decrease is what it is. Yeah. So with that, you also that cell building essential,
the human immune and also the lymphatic system, you know, you have lymph vessels and nodes throughout
your body, lymph is that clear fluid that goes throughout through all the way to the heart. And you have
this kind of interconnected system, if you will, that really can cause a lot of problems. If you have
chronic fatigue or stiffness or, you know, bloating or brain fog headaches a lot of people struggle with
headaches and you might have an issue with that system. You need to have a solid sewer system and
that's really part of your body. The lymphatic system is a sewer system. So if you have skin problems,
cellulite, those types of things usually, you know, rebounding can help. Obviously, nutrition,
herbal therapies, you know, there are a whole host of things that you can do. But so that's the
second, that's the second triad triad. And again, this goes into more detail in the book. But just
for our listeners, say, I'm going to try to be brief on the next part because the third one is
energized. And essentially, that's when we rely on the Holy Spirit. So you need a healthy nervous system.
Brain health, you know, don't stay up late watching TV and eating garbage like Doritos on your couch
at night because you're not giving your nervous system what it needs to go to bed. So meditation,
omega-3 fatty acids, getting good, good walnuts, walnuts, or shaped like brains. I think that's
the reason why we should probably eat them. It's good for the brain. Intermittent asking all of the
things can help with brain health, just making sure you're getting adequate sleep and so on.
And this is something that fascinated me in my study because I didn't know much about it, but the
autonomic nervous system is something that was really new to me in my research. And you have a sympathetic
system. That is your reaction to stress. That is when your adrenaline kicks in. The body is on.
You're sort of focused. You're in that mode. But then you have the parasympathetic system. That's
your cooldown function, your relaxation mode. The body's off. And a lot of those things just happen.
You know, that's why they're autonomic. They just, you don't tell yourself to breathe. You don't tell
yourself to pump blood. You just, it just happens. And that's one of the things I think that this whole
COVID debacle has done is really messed with people's autonomic nervous systems because everything's
just stressful. You know, you can't even just go to the store without being hassled about a mask,
at least early on. That's how it was. So people were having a hard time balancing that. And working
from home became this new thing for a lot of people. But keeping that in balance is huge. It helps with
exercise, getting sleep. It was Dr. Bergman who said, make sure you're sleeping under 70 degrees.
Just don't, don't, don't put your health and jeopardy by, you know, basically being irresponsible
with what you're eating and when you're eating it and staying up late and then trying to function the
next day. Those are all aspects to that cell building essential. Grounding is another thing. I'm doing
it right now, actually, as we talk. Grounding that underneath. And, you know, just discharging the
body of all those electrons that it's acquiring through EMF exposure. You know, that's one of the
big issues, especially with the 5G technology, which is interesting. There's some great studies by
Dr. Thomas Cowan connecting that and showing how that could be a huge, huge contributor to what we're
calling COVID-19. Yeah, pretty scary studies. Yeah, you're basically, we're basically putting people
in a microwave 24-7. And it's not good. Cell building essential 6 is healthy blood brain bones,
your skin, your circulatory respiratory system. I think a lot of that's pretty self-explanatory.
Make sure you have clean blood keeping all of those issues at bay, hypertension. A lot of these
things that doctors will just prescribe a pill for, well, you could get it under control by reducing
inflammation in your body, which is essentially what cholesterol does. Cluster of all the LDL comes
and helps the low density lipoprotein helps repair the veins. It helps the body repair. And so it's not
because of cholesterol that you have these issues. It's because you have issues with inflammation
in your body. You're eating too much McDonald's and Taco Bell, right? Perhaps bones and joints. This
is another one that it's fascinating to me to a lot of the, you know, alopathic medical doctors
just don't have right. Your osteoclats and you have osteoblasts, the clats and the blasts.
The clats help take down and, you know, get rid of the unnecessary bone tissue and then osteoblasts
come along and they put new bone down. Well, these drugs that they give people who have things like
osteoporosis, they're not giving the osteoblasts what they need to rebuild. So you're not
getting the nutrition. You're not getting the things you need. You're not getting something
like calcium, which your body does need for bone density. And so all of those things are connected
skin health the same way. Leaky gut, massive problem, the way our western diet is and feeding all
of these other skin diseases, acne, cold sores, you know, psoriasis. All of those things are all connected.
And so that's the sixth cell butting essential. And I'll just wrap it up. The seventh one is a healthy
spiritual system. And frankly, that's the foundation of the entire house. We've already talked about
it earlier, but your whole creatures were made in the image of God. We're not merely biological or
merely spiritual. We are, we are both. So how, how we handle stress and adversity, joy and celebration,
all of that is rooted in our world and life view. All of that's connected to who it is. God has made
us to be. And so we need to have that foundation in place. Well, that's excellent.
Will you do a great job, summarize it. And I know people are going to want to get your book. We'll
have access to it on this podcast for everybody. Do you want to close us in prayer? Yeah. Yeah, absolutely.
I appreciate you. I just say that to Dr. Conner's having me on. I appreciate your work and
massively respect what you're doing there and helping people and really applying this stuff. So
I hope, I hope you continue to minister to thousands and thousands of people. That would be my prayer.
But so thank you for the opportunity. Come on and talk. Yeah, thank you for coming. It's just been,
it's been great. It's, it's so neat to see. I mean, I've been in this fight for 30 some years.
And you grow weary, especially when you're talking to believers who have already just sold out
to the to the cult. And it is, it's refreshing. I was, I was refreshed to see your book when you
sent me the original copy to read and to give my endorsement for. So I just, I thank you for what
you're doing. Yeah. Well, praise God. I appreciate that. And now more than ever, do we need clarity
on these issues? Oh, it's definitely. But people really need to get their, their, their understanding
of terrain theory and understanding, you know, the importance of the body. And so I, I, I really pray
that your work and hopefully mine will be blessed and used by God, mightily. So yeah, let's, let's pray.
Heavenly Father, we have come and to, to talk and discuss these things that are most important. And I
do pray for those who are listening and watching that they would be blessed by what's discussed here,
Lord. And I, I just pray that you would restore us and give us, give us health, or we know that in your
word, there, there is a grand vision of redemption and the restoration of the world. And we certainly look
forward to that. But we pray here. And now that you would help us, equip us so that we can be self-governed
in this most important area. And Lord, we pray against the darkness, we pray against the evil that's
being perpetrated on us and, and other people across the world with this sort of globalest,
status control. We pray against it and pray that you would crush your enemies, Lord, bring them to
a knowledge of you and your son, Jesus, who died for our sins and rose for our justification.
We're going to help us to, to navigate these tumultuous waters and, and may, may our time
hear and in the future be stewarded well and honorable to you and Christ's name I pray. Amen.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, Pastor. Again, I appreciate all you guys listening. And we just
want to bring back great guests like this and share just wonderful information. Thank you,
again, Jason. Appreciate it. Thank you. All right. Bye-bye.